[Music]
in a recent massive development on this
very specific story i've been falling
for my own pleasure on the side
um the makers of a device that was
created to fix the mcdonald's ice cream
machines the mcflurry the broken
mcflurry machines
are now suing mcdonald's wow
for creating the same device
wait so they made their own yeah
starting starting way at the beginning
of all this [ __ ] when
mcdonald's first formed
they had the ice cream machine being in
an exclusive contract with a different
company called taylor so uh taylor's
like the
soft-serve machine that commercial like
everyone uses yeah and let's say you're
like let's say you're you're you got a
mcdonald's franchise you have to use
taylor okay you can't just make some
random like ice cream from some other
machine it's like i joined nato and i'm
a new country and i have to buy all
these weapons yeah right i feel like
that's american made i got it yeah so a
lot of your money is gonna go into uh
you know keeping this thing maintained
and uh
when uh when a lot of employees were
asked like dude why is the ice cream
machine always broken um it's because an
error code will come up that says only a
licensed technician from taylor can fix
this right now so they just can't touch
it
that's part of the agreement as a if you
have a franchise you can't just [ __ ]
fix it because you have to get rid of
the error code kind of like when uh you
do obd2 on your car and like you have to
turn off the check engine light it's
like if you turn it totally like that
yeah yeah no i'm gonna say the same
thing yeah being bar we're talking about
that earlier that's what i was saying
classic obd2 man [ __ ] right yeah man
dude i know cars bro have you seen the
same documentary yeah it's great yeah i
watch the same thing and so
basically
they make so much [ __ ] money from
just repairs that they're just like yeah
i mean it's a part of the business plan
it's planned obviously
but it's been going on for so long and
most of the time this technician
would go in there and really just turn
the code off doesn't really actually fix
anything that's [ __ ] and then they
couldn't really prove it until like
finally this um other company
made a device that actually shows you
what is wrong with it
it's like a usb thing right you plug it
in and most of the time nothing was
really wrong with it wow it just like
regularly
every quarter or every month or whatever
or every week so this machine is just
pretty much set up to break but it also
is like um
i think overnight you have to have it on
the cleaning thing and all that but it's
easy to like trip up that coat like that
error
because you have to you know clean it
overnight and that's why they go oh we
don't have any [ __ ] soft serve right
now it's broken i feel like it's been
happening a lot less recently well yes
it actually has because this company
called kitsch were the ones to create
that device that uh different people who
owned mcdonald's franchise could buy
that and then just use that and see
what's wrong with it or just or just be
able to block that code from even
happening
because it's like oh nothing's actually
wrong with it so it's just not going to
give you that error that makes you have
to shut down the machine so it wasn't
mcdonald's that was lying it was taylor
the stupid taylormade well mcdonald's
has an exclusive contract with them they
benefit from taylor having to be fixed
all the time apparently
it's a racket between taylor and
mcdonald's and the people that are
within those
businesses that are shaking hands
yeah so it's not actually mcdonald's
corporate and actually tailor it's like
people in that company figuring out how
to like yeah
right right right who would have thought
so then what happened is uh
after people started using the kitsch
device
mcdonald's obviously not knowing what to
do they got it they've they set up a lab
reverse engineered what that device does
and they basically just created their
own
mcdonald's so they're like well [ __ ] it
we don't need to make we just have we
won't have broken ones so they
completely put kitsch out of business
and now kitch is suing them for
unfair competition wait oh kitchen oh
kitchen kitchen i thought it was taylor
i thought taylor would do no taylor's
not suing
taylor's safe and rich yeah
kitch is the one suing for for
mcdonald's eliminating them okay yeah
from a thing they'd always refuse to
address and they they mcdonald's never
address it until kitsch was solving the
taylor problem exactly and now
mcdonald's wanted to wipe kitchen out
for doing that and in doing so now kitch
is like hey we're suing you for
destroying our entire company mcdonald's
doesn't want to sell milkshakes after a
certain hour just say that like
breakfast dude just tell me that i'm
[ __ ] into my face
a lot of companies do that though like
when uh the first iphone came out i
believe they were looking for some sort
of touch screen company
um and then so when they would just buy
out like five companies that are are
doing that technology just to
eliminate any other threats from popping
up there's like a list of conspiracies
that became true right and one of them
is um
one of the
age-old questions of
why is there no public transportation in
la like we had a rail system or if you
go to downtown la you see all these
rails and it's because the auto industry
created fake rail companies to buy up
all the rails and all the trolleys just
so they could rip them out wow so
there's no competition for public
transportation
to the first gen of electric vehicles oh
yeah they all got bought up by auto
yeah
i mean business is like warfare dude
they [ __ ] they're ruthless that is
like that is conspiracy [ __ ] too even
though it's documented i [ __ ] love it
that's some [ __ ] little foil hat [ __ ]
amazon basics does that [ __ ] though yeah
yeah
i remember there was a story about like
a tripod that happened like that
somebody put like a tripod built it made
it really like a user friendly in this
simple cheap way started hitting mad
sales so that amazon built the same
thing and then banned that person from
selling
wow they're not shutting down the
company they're saying yeah you can't
sell here anymore between that and like
what they do with shelf space like at
grocery stores it's the same idea right
right
we can do a generic of your product and
we'll move you wherever the [ __ ] we want
yeah
true
like kirkland kirkland great great
company so i guess like that's when it
falls into the terms of what is fair
competition and there are laid out laws
for that and
what uh kitch is trying to do is prove
that what they did was technically
unfair which yeah because it was so
specific what's that because it's like
so specific yeah i think it's the way
they did it you're not allowed to do
what mcdonald's did where you can't like
get the actual product and then
reverse engineer it in a lab to make the
exact same like did kiss not patent it
they did but i don't know there's
something about like the way that they
went about it is not the way that maybe
even at like mcdonald's crossing
industries like that
because it's food right and they're just
going straight into technology to wipe
someone out right yeah yeah i think it's
something along those lines where it's
like rich people are [ __ ] worth or
ruthless right yeah like i know i knew a
guy who um they were doing earthquake um
fasteners and they patented this
earthquake fastener
so like you can you you have furniture
in your house you have bookshelves like
right here where it's like super unsafe
and like these bookshelves if there was
an earthquake they'd probably follow me
and i'd probably die right now well you
have earthquake fastener you bolt it to
your wall and then it's like it also
like gets attached to the shelving and
so it doesn't fall down well
um they were selling it for like you
know 50 cents a unit and then they're
but they're like is what the cost was
but then they're charging like like 20
bucks
well the patent that the person got this
um earthquake fastener with the the
person the partner for the patent
he was getting a share of every sale
and then um the guy that i know he's
like
i'm tired of paying this guy
i'll just hire this other company
to figure out how to reverse engineer my
own patent do it differently patent that
i'll just [ __ ] sell that instead
cut out that guy
and then i already paid the company a
fee to like develop this and they don't
care about licensing
so
cut that guy out and boom
this happens so often it's crazy it's so
mean
it's so [ __ ] mean it's so mean like
some a lot of the number one and two
a lot of the number one and two
companies that one of the guys that
started the second company would have
worked for like the first one like in
drums like there's like symbols like
sabian and zildjian they're like they
were like once related like those
there's so many companies that are like
that oh they're all like breakaways yeah
like i don't know i'll be making this up
but it'd be like let's say chevy used to
be with ford or something you know but
you hear so many stories like that oh
yeah but imagine like we
built this to together this device
together yeah and now i'm just tired of
having you be part of it i'm gonna
[ __ ] [ __ ] you that's so crazy
ruthless
i get if they had like a falling out or
like a difference in how to
i don't know like the philosophy of the
company and i mean that always happens
right splits happen but then when it
comes to man i don't want to pay you
anymore that's just [ __ ] shitty if
you worked on it together that's a
change in the philosophy of the company
even if even if you had it falling out
it's it's
that's cute and all but
you guys still did this together so
that's true so you should get paid for
what you've created together and just
leave it at that move on to a different
venture
that is pretty ruthless though
or by the other person now like whatever
you know like try to do it like the
fairway yeah rather than just you're not
getting a diamond rather than just
starting a competing business yeah well
it's really they honestly i just think
that they were bored and they're like
trying to get cute about things which
rich people often do like okay like how
can i even maximize even more of this
like get more for myself that's that
stuff's usually in contrast so right
with operating agreements right off top
it's like you know a major officer can't
leave and like within a certain period
of time create a competing element
that should be but think about patent
law patent law is totally different
where it's like this it's the
application of the idea in this unique
way right well if you can somehow do it
in a different way that is also unique
you can just repatent it
resell it nobody and people like playing
games like so like let's say that the
non-compete uh clause or whatever right
let's say the penalty is a million
dollars and this was like but if i do
this i can make 15. i'll make the 15 pay
you a million
look at apple
apple and the galaxy phones right the
samsung was just like you know what [ __ ]
it we'll rip off apple and we'll just
pay the fee later and they did in
pennies they saved their business they
paid the the billion dollar fee and
pennies and they made billions yeah it's
just how business isn't that's true yeah
you just wait till you get the ticket
yep that's what they do with music a lot
too they'll sample something and be like
hey they actually hear it and they catch
us i guess it just depends on how much
you value the relationship and value
like everything and like and if you can
become an ethical issue yeah or the
integrity of innovation but [ __ ] that
right
hey dude if i go to five-star
restaurants i think i can live with the
guilt i guess
right okay after this we're going to the
strip club we'll get bottle service i
hope i live with the guilt
[Music]
[Music]
foreign